it's that time again to talk to you
about the latest games in new releases
and this week you're on the roller
coaster to hell thanks to scream ride
coming exclusively to current and last
gen xbox in what it seems like the best
parts of roller coaster tycoon you get
to create coasters the way you see fit
even if that means people don't always
make it out alive solid mix of dark
violence and sheer fun as you create the
most dastardly and dangerous rides wield
the power on the third next up a
PlayStation exclusive that puts humans
in a fantastic militaristic future to do
battle with giant alien bugs in a fight
for survival I actually just read the
summary of Starship Troopers but it
completely fits this game so it's
alright you and three your buddies can
work together to kill gross bugs robots
cyborgs and other stuff while you
capture points and destroy beacons but
friendly fire is on so remember who
you're fighting against unless you're a
joke take down anything not human on the
third the second episode of resident
evil revelations 2 comes out this week
so you can keep up with the story of
Barry Burton and that girl in her pjs
there's more secrets to uncover in New
Horrors to discover and there's lots
more content and raid mode if you're
feeling trigger-happy with daily
missions you can always come back to
kill more inflicted when you can unlock
guns and active skills and sweet
gestures like this get your dance moves
on starting on the 3rd there's some
wacky science going on this week with
shift links coming out on current-gen
consoles and PC this week this co-op
adventure bounds you to your partner
with some sort of sciency umbilical cord
and has you go through space passing gas
between each other to complete tasks
whoever gets the gas expands into this
giant ball and gets heavier so they can
use their weight to the advantage in the
puzzles while the other one stays skinny
fluid there's over 50 levels and five
different environments that you can
share both locally and online so if this
gravitates your way you can pass some
gas on the fourth Nintendo creates a
lemming style game you can try out this
week with Mario vs. Donkey Kong tipping
stars there's a lot of unfortunate
accidents that can happen to those
lemmings if you're not careful so pay
attention to your marching mario's and
your marching peaches as they traverse
precarious environments there's also a
handy level editor that allow you to
share and play levels with creators from
all over the world this lands on your
3ds and Wii U on the fifth and finally I
can't let you go without a quick trip to
ollie world because Ollie Ollie too is
making its way to ps4 and Vita this week
so you can bust out that sick nollie
double laser flip 180 in a bunch of new
locations that offer split levels and
secret hidden areas to uncover and even
an upcoming multiplayer get flip in
March third for further details visit
gamespot com release dates are based on
retailer listings and are subject to
change see you next week